[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro de parlement hebdo
l'émission qui revient sur les temps
forts de l'actualité à l'assemblée et au
sénat est avec moi pour présenter cette
émission tam tran huy bonjour tam
bonjour brigitte et pour passer en revue
tous les sujets de la semaine notre
invité philippe dallier bonjour vous
êtes sénateur de seine-saint-denis et
cette âme qui brosse votre portrait
philippe dallier vous êtes né à
levallois-perret dans les hauts-de-seine
mais l'appel des terres séquano
dionysiennes a été plus fort vous avez
longer le fleuve jusqu'à la seine saint
denis dont vous êtes les luttes depuis
37 ans sénateur depuis 2004 vous occuper
la fonction de vice-président de la
chambre autres votre signe distinctif la
longévité de votre implantation locale
vous avez notamment aussi été maire des
pavillons sous bois pendant 22 ans
un mot d'abord de ce territoire philippe
dallier la seine saint denis ce
département qui a été particulièrement
touchée par le cos vide avec une
importante surmortalité comment se passe
le déconfinement et comment s'en sortir
les choses vont mieux
voilà les hôpitaux sont nettement moins
un sous tension le déconfinement se
passe plutôt bien je veux dire plutôt
bien parce qu'effectivement on sait que
dans certains quartiers ça a été plus
difficile qu'ailleurs donc les choses
s'améliorent plutôt positif ful on
poursuit avec les titres de cette
émission est à la une de l'actualité
cette semaine le sénat qui va lancer sa
commission d' enquête sur la gestion des
crises du coc vide 19 début des travaux
fin juin la loi prolongeant l'état
d'urgence sanitaire est entré en vigueur
après le feu vert du conseil
constitutionnel les sages ont censuré
deux points partiellement le traçage et
l'isolément des malades
la loi contre la haine en ligne
définitivement votée à l'assemblée
nationale elle oblige les plateformes à
retirer les contenus haineux sous 24
heures la droite sénatoriale très
opposés à une forme de privation de
liberté d'expression va saisir le
conseil constitutionnel
premier thème donc le sénat qui lance
une commission d' enquête sur la crise
sanitaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le principe était acté restait à
déterminer la date ça sera fin juin
objectif de cette commission denquête
faire la lumière sur ce qui s'est mal
passé dans la gestion de l'épidémie de
kobe 19 et en tirer les conséquences
pour l'avenir explique les sénateurs les
sénateurs qui nie vouloir faire le
procès de l'exécutif jérôme radier
gérard larcher on a informé les
sénateurs ce mercredi il y aura bien une
commission d' enquête sur la gestion de
la crise sanitaire du coc vie 19 mai
alors que certains voulaient qu'elle
démarre au plus vite
elle ne se mettra finalement en place
qu'une fois le plus dur de la crise
passée non qu'elle sera votée
vraisemblablement vers le 23 juin donc
en conférence des présidents avant et le
23 juin sans doute en séance ce qui
permettra de lancer la commission
denquête à la fin du mois de juin
donc quand j'espère on sera un peu
décalé de l'épidémie malgré ce délai
cela risque de tendre les relations
entre le sénat et l'exécutif
selon l'hebdomadaire le canard enchaîné
emmanuel macron se serait exprimé à ce
sujet lors du conseil des ministres en
ces termes le sénat s'est déshonoré le
temps est encore à l'action ce n'est pas
le moment de jouer les procureurs la
politique c'est comme la grammaire
on fait parfois des fautes de temps la
crainte du chef de l'état que les
sénateurs de droite comme de gauche
utilise cette commission denquête pour
faire le procès du gouvernement mais
côté palais du luxembourg
on se défend d'une telle intention je
pense que le grand intérêt de la
commission denquête c'est pas de faire
le procès des accusés c'est que cette
crise qui risque de se renouveler avec
un virus qui revient en hiver prochain
ou avec un autre virus ou avec une autre
catastrophe sanitaire on a vu qu'on n'y
était pas préparé cette commission
denquête ce pour boissons grand intérêt
c'est de prévoir la prochaine crise
cette commission denquête ne pourra de
toute manière pas aborder certains
sujets notamment tout ce sur quoi la
justice est déjà saisi séparation des
pouvoirs oblige
ce qui n'empêchera pas les sénateurs
d'interroger le fonctionnement passé et
présent des plus hautes instances de
l'état sur l'anticipation d'une crise
sanitaire
philippe dallier d'abord votre réaction
à ces propos d' emmanuel macron qui ont
été rapportés par le canard enchaîné le
sénat s'est déshonoré le temps est
encore à lax
ce n'est pas le moment de jouer les
procureurs à ce que ce n'est pas trop
tôt pour déclencher cette commission
denquête j'espère surtout que les propos
rapportés n'ont pas été tenues parce que
le président de la république en conseil
des ministres s'en prennent au parlement
de cette manière là alors là je pense
effectivement que toutes les bornes
serait dépassé faut quand même se
souvenir que et c'est notre constitution
le parlement a deux fonctions voter la
loi et contrôler l'exécutif et le
parlement est dans son droit le plus
strict en déclenchant cette commission
denquête alors je peux comprendre que
c'est ce que les gars assis mais trop
tôt écouter on a entendu claude malhuret
s'exprimer le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est que claude malhuret ne fais pas
partie de ceux qui s'opposent au
gouvernement à tout prix en plus il est
médecin épidémiologiste vous l'entendez
dire effectivement qu'il faut se pencher
sur la situation dans laquelle se
trouvait ce pays au début
effectivement de cette crise parce que
le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est que
nous n'y étions pas préparés
donc il faut comprendre pourquoi s'agit
pas d'aller pointer du doigt untel ou
untel
effectivement le risque c'est que une
partie de ping pong pour se renvoyer les
responsabilités il faut d'abord
comprendre pourquoi effectivement ce
pays s'est retrouvé dépourvu de masques
dépourvu de tests n'ayant rien anticiper
les français ont besoin compote bruno
retailleau quel président du groupe
l'est républicain au sénat
je cite qu'ils répondent de leurs actes
est-ce que vous ne comptez pas réglé
finalement des comptes politiques avec
l'émission d'arc est franchement vous
n'avez pas à vous en tant que française
envie de comprendre pourquoi
effectivement ce pays s'est retrouvé
dépourvu de masque pendant des semaines
on nous a expliqué que les masques
étaient inutiles mais en fait on nous a
dit cela parce que tout simplement on en
avait pas et puis maintenant on voudrait
l'imposer à tout le monde dans l'espace
public
donc voilà il ya eu un vrai problème
c'est trop se fait pas le procès avant
le
avant la commission dont je cherche à
comprendre pourquoi effectivement on
avait un milliard de masques à la fin
des années en fin 2008 2009
on s'est retrouvé avec 750 millions de
masques en 2017
et puis il en restait 113 114 millions
au début de l'année voulez pas
comprendre pourquoi donc il faut
effectivement se réorganiser
différemment donc il faut voir qui a
pris les décisions moi je je je me
pointe du doigt le quinquennat prévue
écoutez l'album n'est pas imputable qu'à
l'exécutif mais ça fait des années que
les stocks ne pas renouveler sonne le
dit cela il est clair qu'il ya eu un
changement de doctrine en 2009 après la
période
roselyne bachelot il ya eu un changement
de doctrine mais la nouvelle doctrine
n'a pas été mise en oeuvre
et ça a eu des conséquences jusqu'à
effectivement cette situation de début
d'année 2020 où on s'est trouvé à
dépourvu complètement alors que d'autres
pays européens ou gérer cette crise de
manière beaucoup plus efficace donc les
français ont le droit de savoir et nous
nous avons l'obligation de comprendre
justement pour pouvoir adapter la
manière dont nous gérons une éventuelle
crise à l'avenir
sur le fond on aime ça va créer de la
tension avec l'exécutif on sent déjà
quand même bien utile et dans le
contexte actuel on est encore dans mais
franchement alors il est à quoi sert le
parlement selon vous dans une démocratie
comme la nôtre si effectivement le
parlement ne doit en matière de vote de
la loi pas déposer d'amendement qui
chagrine les ministres et si
effectivement en matière de contrôle de
l'action du gouvernement nous ne devons
nous contenter que de dire des choses
sympathiques mais franchement les plus
larges une démocratie normale se
souvient quand même on a tous en mémoire
la sphère benalla et cette commission d'
enquête qui avait tendu fortement les
relations entre le sénat et l'exécutif
est-ce que vous ne croyez pas que ça
risque d'envenimer un peu plus les
choses côté on veut ni mais je ne sais
pas mais que mais pourquoi est ce que
pour porte pourquoi d'ailleurs pour
essayer de lisser les choses ne faire en
sorte qu'ils aient pas de débat dans ce
pays mais qu'elle elle kestrel intérêt
franchement donc il faut comprendre donc
pour comprendre cette commission aura
six mois c'est une période relativement
longue elle va le pouvoir auditionner et
j'espère qu'effectivement nous
comprendront ce qui s'est passé et
surtout que le gouvernement pourra
s'appuyer sur les résultats de la
commission dans 4
mais pour corriger les choses tout
simplement parce que c'est quand même ça
l'objectif qu'ils souhaitaient voix
entendre qui souhaitez-vous auditionnés
moi je ne suis pas je ne sais pas qui
sera membre de cette commission qui sera
relativement large mais tous ceux qui
ont eu des décisions à prendre deux vont
effectivement être auditionné alors ils
sont nombreux manifestement d'après ce
que j'ai pu lire dans la presse depuis
un certain temps il ya beaucoup de
plaintes qui ont été déposées contre des
membres de l'exécutif du gouvernement 63
plaintes
est-ce que d'une part vous trouvez que
c'est exagéré ou pas et d'autre part
est-ce que c'est plein de vont pas vous
empêcher de travailler on sait que quand
il ya une affaire en justice la
commission denquête ne peut pas entendre
comme elles le souhaitent les ministres
a effectivement cessé la règle lorsque
la justice est saisie donc sur ces
points particuliers on ne peut pas
interférer
on nous disait déjà la même chose dans
le cadre de la sphère benalla et pour
autant la commission bancaire du sénat
s'est concentré conformément à la
constitution effectivement sur les
parties de la sphère qui n'était pas
dans les mains de la justice nous feront
exactement la même chose
allez hop haussier cette émission avec
dans l'actualité également la censure
partielle du conseil constitutionnel sur
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les sages ont validé globalement la loi
mais émis des réserves sur le traçage et
l'isolément des malades
il avait été saisi par le président la
république le président du sénat mais
aussi l'opposition de gauche fabien rey
caire les sages ont validé la loi qui
prolonge l'état d'urgence sanitaire
mais avec des réserves sur le traitement
des données personnelles à des fins de
traçage de l'épidémie le conseil
constitutionnel émette une censure
partielle les organismes sociaux
notamment ne devront pas avoir accès à
ces données
garantir leur confidentialité sera de la
responsabilité de l'état reculé à nos
combats parce qu'on ne voulait pas que
trop de personnes puissent avoir accès
aux données médicales et les fameuses
brigades des anges gardiens formule
consacrée par notamment le ministre vers
en moi je préfère parler de suivi
épidémiologique ne peut pas se faire
dans n'importe quelles conditions un
autre garde-fou concerne la mise en
quarantaine des malades considérés comme
privative de liberté dans certains cas
elle devra être soumise au contrôle d'un
juge des libertés gérard larcher y voit
un apport du sénat
eh bien je pense que le conseil a validé
mais qu'il a apporté un certain nombre
de précisions voir de restriction qui
correspondent aux faux débats du sénat
les juges des libertés par exemple c'est
le sénat qui l'a introduit quelques âmes
pourra pas être empêché de se déplacer
plus de douze heures sans éventuellement
l'intervention du juge des libertés
quant à l'article 1 qui encadre la
responsabilité pénale des élus en cas de
catastrophe sanitaire
il ne ferait que rappeler le droit
commun juge le conseil constitutionnel
des parlementaires de gauche redoutait
que des membres du gouvernement puissent
s'abriter derrière cet article afin de
s'exonérer de leurs responsabilités au
lendemain de la crise du coronavirus
philippe dallier finalement voyez le
verre à moitié vide ou le verre à moitié
plein puisque finalement l'exécutif
s'est félicité de la validation de la
loi l'opposition se félicite des deux
censure partielle tout le monde est
content je le verrais plutôt à moitié
plein et d'ailleurs je rappellerai qu'il
y avait eu un accord en cmp sur ce texte
est examiné compromis
d'autres un texte de compromis entre
l'assemblée nationale et laissez-la
comme l'a rappelé le président larcher
sur l'article 6 effectivement le sénat
avait treize orienter les choses dans la
direction d'ailleurs qui a été souligné
par le conseil constitutionnel même si
sur cette partie si c'est le fichage
utilisé cette expression mais
effectivement c'est tout ce qui donne la
possibilité de contraindre effectivement
ceux qui seraient infectées par le virus
et puis il ya aussi la validation de
l'article 1er qu'est-ce qu'on n'avait
pas entendu de la part de la garde des
sceaux notamment sur la soi disant
volonté d' amnistie des parlementaires
ce qu'on va y revenir mais pour pour
parler de la socio du partiel en tout
cas un du conseil constitutionnel est ce
que pour vous ça remet complètement en
question la stratégie du gouvernement
qui était testé tracé est isolé non ça
ne remet pas du tout en cause cette
stratégie mais la question est qui est
de savoir d'abord qui a accès à quelles
informations il ya effectivement des
données qui sont des données sensibles
qui ont trait au secret médical
n'importe qui ne peut pas avoir accès à
ces données ensuite il ya les garanties
qui ont été apportées on peut
contraindre effectivement les gens s'ils
sont contaminés par le virus mais pour
autant il faut garantir leur liberté
fondamentale garantie pour vous tous les
cas le avec les précisions apportées si
je puis dire par le conseil
constitutionnel
je pense qu'on a un texte équilibré et
qui va être efficace et utile sur le
terrain
insatisfait la cnil mais on est quand
même sur un fil sur cette affaire de
fichage penser que ça va être efficace
dans ses mails écouter dans ces domaines
là on est toujours effectivement sur le
fil du rasoir
soit on tombe d'un côté et on est
effectivement on peut aller au delà de
ce qui est nécessaire en matière de
privation des libertés ou en matière
d'accès aux données personnelles ou
alors on n'est pas suffisamment on ne
cadre pas suffisamment les choses et on
n'est pas efficace donc on l'a peut-être
trouver le bon compromis en tous les cas
je l'espère juste un mot sur le fait que
lundi finalement on a été dans une forme
de vide juridique puisqu'il ya eu le
déconfinement qui avait pas encore eu et
bien cette décision du conseil
constitutionnel
vous pensez que c'était un couac pour
vous ça tient au fait que le
gouvernement nous demande d'examiner des
textes dans des
délais qui sont extrêmement courts le
sénat et l'assemblée ont eu une semaine
pour examiner ce texte
une semaine seulement il fallait ensuite
c'était que le conseil constitutionnel
se prononce donc le texte a été adopté
dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche
le conseil constitutionnel avait une
journée ou un peu plus pour
effectivement examiner un texte
important et qui posait des questions
donc fanny le texte a été validé lundi
relativement tardivement bon c'est ainsi
et la faute à l'exécutif quoi en tous
les cas il faut en tirer une leçon il
faut que le parlement retrouve les
moyens en terme de temps pour examiner
correctement les textes on comprend on
est dans une crise il y avait
effectivement nécessité d' aller
relativement vite mais bon on a examiné
quatre textes jusqu'à présent dans des
conditions complètement hors norme en
matière de temps d'examen temps en
commission que dans l'hémicycle il faut
que ça s'arrête maintenant il faut qu'on
retrouve le temps de travailler dans des
délais corrects
après cela vous nous parliez de
l'article 20 de la responsabilité pénale
des élus l'état d'urgence rappelle donc
enfin ce projet de loi le droit commun
finalement est ce que la loi dite
fauchon qui date de 2000 finalement et
qui donne encadrant fait la
responsabilité pénale des élus locaux
est-ce qu'elle n'était pas suffisante
finalement on a considéré que dans une
crise qu'il tout à fait particulière
puisque on est face à une situation que
nous ne comprenons pas complètement
puisque comment va évoluer le virus
quelles sont les bonnes mesures à
prendre
certains effectivement conteste
aujourd'hui encore l'efficacité d'une
telle ou telle mesure donc on est dans
une situation complètement mouvante la
loi fauchon à l'époque elle précisait
les choses
effectivement dans quels cas pouvait-on
aller rechercher la responsabilité d'un
maire si un panneau de basket
s'écroulait là les choses s'il puis dire
elles sont assez le figer assez clair là
on est dans situe à situation
complètement différente et on a voulu
effectivement dire et rappeler qu'il
faudra que le juge parce que on pourra
toujours avaient attaqué un maire un
ministre ou qui que ce soit ayant des
responsabilités il faudrait que le juge
prenne en compte cette situation
particulière voilà ça n'est que cela que
nous avons
et nous n'avons pas du tout cherché à
amnistie qui que ce soit comme a pu le
dire la garde des sceaux dans des propos
pour les mères ni achement ce certains
ministres le conseil constitutionnel
vient de dire que le texte était
conforme à la constitution je pense que
ça clôt le débat et j'espère que ceux
qui avait tenu des propos comme celui là
les regrette aujourd'hui
mais justement le conseil
constitutionnel sur ce point il dit le
texte ne fait que rappeler le droit
commun donc finalement le texte
n'apporte pas énormément de choses par
rapport à la situation antérieure
on se demande aussi à quoi ça c'est ce
que savait pas une dimension
électoraliste mais c'est avant tout dans
les noms n'ont absolument pas je pense
que peut-être que vous ne mesurez pas
l'inquiétude qu'il y avait je vais vous
parler des élus locaux mais c'est la
même chose chez les chefs d'entreprise
et chez tous ceux qui ont eu des
décisions à prendre
vous ne mesurez pas l'inquiétude
effectivement de tout cela à qui on
disait faut faire revenir travailler
personnel il faut ré ouvrir les écoles
mais on ne sait pas dans quelles
conditions effectivement on va pouvoir
efficacement lutter contre ce virus donc
comprenait l'inquiétude de tout cela et
donc le fait de dire ça va être quand
les textes ont relativement vague le
juge être un très grand pouvoir
d'appréciation
là nous n'avons pas changé le fond mais
nous avons précisé les choses en disant
que le juge devra effectivement se
former son jugement
en tenant compte expressément des
conditions liées à cette pandémie parler
des grands électeurs des mers juste une
dernière question est ce que vous êtes
favorable parce que le deuxième tour des
élections municipales se tiennent au
mois de juin
si bien sûr l'épidémie dont byrnes
empire pas d'ici là si nous sommes dans
les conditions d'aujourd'hui je pense
qu'elles pourront se tenir mais ça on le
saura dans deux trois semaines quand
effectivement on pourra voir ce que le
déconfinement à donner je pense que s'il
est possible effectivement de les tenir
fin juin il faut les tenir fin juin
parce que reportée à l'automne ça veut
dire est organisé deux tours décaler les
campagnes vous croyez qu'elle ne seront
pas un peu faussée on voit bien que les
gens ne se sont pas déplacés en masse au
premier tour est ce que ça ne risque pas
d'être le cas une deuxième fois notez
que ça soit en juin ou en septembre est
ce que vous pensez que de ce point de
vue là les choses ont fondamentalement
changé moi je ne le pense pas vraiment
donc si on peut les tenir en juin fin
juin à la condition expresse que la
pandémie ne reprennent pas bien
mon une folle faire lé film d'aliens ont
continué à l actu de l'assemblée le
projet de loi portant sur diverses
mesures d'urgence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le parlement va autoriser une nouvelle
fois le gouvernement à légiférer par
ordonnance le projet de loi relatifs à
diverses dispositions liées à la crise
sanitaire à d'autres mesures urgentes
ainsi qu'au retrait du royaume uni de
l'union européenne est encore en débat à
l'assemblée les oppositions dénonce tout
la méthode stéphanie des pierres texte
fourre-tout délais d'examen trop court
ordonnance en série sur le fond et
surtout sur la forme
l'opposition fustige ce projet de loi
projet de loi fourre-tout visant à faire
passer pour urgente des dispositions
sans rapport avec le co vite 19 tout en
piétinant le parlement vous viendra
ensuite faire votre marché dans ce texte
fourre-tout afin de légiférer comme bon
vous semblera pour une période allant
bien au delà de l'état d'urgence
prétendu cause de ces demandes
d'habilitation
au fil des discussions le gouvernement a
accepté de réduire le nombre
d'habilitation donc une ordonnance mais
l'opposition reste sceptique face à
cette loi qui couvre une trentaine de
thèmes du breakbeat à la justice en
passant par les saisonniers ou les
irradiés du nucléaire et la réalité si
vous utilisez aussi c'est un prétexte
cette crise sanitaire
certains sujets sont évidemment liés
d'autres beaucoup moins et c'est un
prétexte qui est pris pour éviter de
repasser devant le parlement parce que
vous avez perdu du temps sur des projets
doit avorter retraité adp par exemple la
crise sanitaire n'est pas un prétexte
est un fait qui s'impose à nous qui
nécessite un certain nombre de
dispositions législatives pardonnez moi
de vous le répondre depuis la mi mars
les députés ont travaillé dans l'urgence
avec à chaque fois un délai très court
pour voter les projets de loi liés à
l'épidémie
et c'est pareil pour celui ci les
critiques sur la manière dont fonctionne
l'assemblée au temps du coronavirus ont
ressurgi notamment dans la bouche de ce
député communiste qui interpelle ses
collègues de la majorité ne vous
habituer pas avoir un parlement sous
cloche vous vous habituez à délibérer
par ordonnance est à dire a confié à
l'exécutif le soin de choisir à votre
place vous allez faire la démonstration
que ce parlement ne sert à rien
l'assemblée a
tam est sondé confinement elle devrait
petit à petit retrouver un rythme de
travail plus normal mais seuls 150
députés sur 577 sont autorisés à siéger
dans l'hémicycle
philippe dallier les oppositions à
l'assemblée on critiquer la méthode
finalement est ce qu'il n'est pas normal
de fonctionner par ordonnance alors même
que vous venez de proroger l'état
d'urgence qui octroie des pouvoirs
supplémentaires au gouvernement il n'y a
pas que l'opposition qui a effectivement
pointé le fait que le recours aux
ordonnances devenait excessifs certains
groupes de la majorité à l'assemblée
l'ont fait il y avait encore 33
habilitation par ordonnance dans ce
texte la bon lui semble qu'un effort
sera fait par le gouvernement et
l'assemblée pour en réduire le nombre
mais effectivement il ya un moment où le
parlement doit retrouver tous ses droits
nous sortons d'une période où nous avons
accepté d'examiner quatre textes de
mettre en en urgence absolue nous
l'avons fait ils ont tous été adoptés de
commun accord entre l'assemblée et le
sénat c'est quand même à noter mais on
ne va pas pouvoir continuer ainsi on a
un texte là on va traiter à la fois des
tickets restaurant de la prolongation de
certains contrats de travail du bric
site
on va effectivement traités oui fourre
tout parce que mais il ya des mesures
qui vont avoir un impact fort on va
effectivement le gouvernement le
souhaite que il qu'il puisse
effectivement contraindre certains
organismes publics à aller déposer leur
trésorerie sur des comptes du trésor
on ne sait pas quel organisme public on
ne sait pas pourquoi faire mais on voit
bien l'intention c'est aller chercher
l'argent qui pourrait entre guillemets
dormir ici ou là et le parlement ne
déciderait pas que vous le texte
finalement qui octroie des délais c'est
assez technique c'est vrai il ya des
oeufs des autorisations sur chaque et
dans ce contexte il ya des autorisations
pour légiférer par ordonnances pour 30
mois
trente mois août et il ya probablement
des mesures qu'il fallait prendre tout
de suite on aurait pu effectivement où
les inclure dans le texte précédent
d'ailleurs les pas si vieux ou alors
avoir un nouveau texte sur ces mesures
là et puis sur d'autres sujets excusez
moi mais on pourrait prendre le temps de
faire un travail législatif correct là
le gouvernement confond vitesse et
précipitation je vous concernant
mon corps comme un prétexte vous pensé
pour amoindrir les droits dit pas je
pense que là le gouvernement va trop
loin et d'ailleurs même sa majorité à
l'assemblée réagi et puis moi je vais
raccrocher sa au débat qu'on l'a connu
en début de quinquennat où on nous
expliquait que le parlement était trop
lent qu'il fallait aller plus vite qu'il
fallait restreindre pouvoir d'amendement
avoir besoin dans ce sens au parlement
il a aussi présenté son plan d'urgence
devant le parlement
ça ce sont des marques de respect qu'un
dans ce moment de crise il ya des choses
positives et d'autres qui ne sont pas
mais quand on veut mettre en place la
commission denquête au scénar nous
explique le parlement n'auraient pas le
droit de le faire que si jamais le
moment etc
non franchement il j'espère que nous
allons retrouver un rythme qui est
beaucoup plus compatibles avec un
travail de qualité parce que pourquoi
même se souvenir qu'un on écrit la loi
elle s'applique à tous les français
si on se trompe et ça peut avoir des
conséquences importantes le gouvernement
ferait bien de s'en souvenir et vous
souhaitez effectivement qu'il y ait le
nombre normal de sénateurs deux députés
qu'ils puissent revenir dans l'ensemble
de l'hémicycle
ça c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
effectivement il ya des mesures à
prendre pour limiter les risques de
cette pandémie
ce qu'il faut c'est qu'effectivement est
d'ailleurs le conseil constitutionnel a
statué puisque certains parlementaires
de gauche avaient attaqué sous cet angle
là en disant n'avoir pas pu participer
au débat il faut effectivement qu'on
s'organise pour que tous ceux qui ont un
amendement à défendre puisse le faire
jusqu'à présent ça a été le cas même si
effectivement on veut pas se retrouver à
348 votre actualité c'est l'assemblée
qui a achevé définitivement cette
semaine l'examen de la proposition de
loi a via sur la haine en ligne le texte
a été voté malgré de fortes oppositions
sur tous les bancs de l'assemblée
la droite sénatoriale a décidé de saisir
le conseil constitutionnel
écoutez cet échange à l'assemblée entre
la rapporteure laetitia via l député
insoumis alexis corbière
enfin nous y sommes non pas à
l'aboutissement de ce combat que nous
menons contre la haine sur internet mais
à une étape charnière celle du vote
d'une proposition de loi qui affirme qu
est ce qui n'est pas toléré dans
l'espace public ne peut pas l'être sur
internet que nous ne sommes pas
impuissants
lorsqu'il s'agit d'assurer la protection
de ceux qui sont la cible de cette haine
en raison de ce qu'ils sont dans leur
être dans leur chair
que nous ne nous pouvons encourager à
l'internet dans lequel le débat existera
toujours avec vigueur avec passion mais
en préservant le respect de l'autre
qu'est-ce qu'on ne compte plus et ne
quelque chose qui vous critiquent
quelque chose qui un texte qui a un
verbe un peu dure vis-à-vis de la
politique que vous menez mais par
définition quand on est attaché aux
libertés de la liberté c'est la liberté
d'expression de ses adversaires et vous
maintenez vous mettez la en place au nom
de bonnes intentions
une loi qui en vérité à un éventail
extrêmement large de possibilités
d'intervention car à partir là tout peut
devenir demain en contenu haineux il ya
un déversoir de haine sur les réseaux
sociaux philippe dallier il ya une forme
d'impunité aussi pourquoi avoir saisi le
conseil constitutionnel sur les
objectifs de cette loi
tout le monde ne peut qu'être d'accord
la question c'est les moyens que l'on va
mettre en oeuvre c'est là qu'est le
débat il est bon de toutes les manières
indépendamment du contenu du texte
aujourd'hui il est bon que le conseil
constitutionnel se prononce
le sénat n'a pas souhaité effectivement
voté conforme cette fois ci en tous les
cas trouvé un mac n'a pas pu trouver un
accord avec l'assemblée nationale parce
que nous pensons on verra ce que dit
conseil constitutionnel que les moyens
qui seront mis en oeuvre
où vont trop loin ou laisse trop de
pouvoir effectivement aux plateformes
pour censurer les propos d'untel ou
d'untel sous peine de prison je le
rappelle on va demander à ses
plateformes en 2h ou sous 24 heures de
retirer des preuves des propos sur
lesquels on pourrait discuter sous peine
de prison bon je pense qu'on va trop
loin même si l'objectif est louable mais
côté on va voir ce que va dire le
conseil constitutionnel merci beaucoup
d'avoir fait cette émission philippe
dallier c'est la fin de ces un plaisir
merci à brigitte de la représentation
avec moi à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]